Jesse Smollett heads back to Hollywood
the justice system utterly fails
underage victims of a major political
donor and voter fraud is a reality I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
well we a lot to get to today we are
gonna be talking about an actual
political beating that happened in
Berkeley and that is being treated by
the media as alleged even though it's on
tape because certain types of crime are
important while other types of crime not
important well gets all that in just a
second first in 2008 the u.s. national
debt was 10 trillion dollars today that
set is nearly 22 trillion and it is
rising like a hockey stick if you don't
think we are sitting on a house of cards
who are living with their head in the
sand but since you are listening to this
podcast you are clearly smarter than the
average bear so what is your plan can
you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the S&P dropped 50% what you should do
is hedge at least a little bit against
inflation and uncertainty and
instability get a little bit of precious
metals gold is a safe haven against
uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group and right
now thanks to a little-known IRS tax law
you can even move your IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver which is perfect for people
who want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from any future
geopolitical uncertainty look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard savings Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews
and a plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact Birch gold group
get a free information kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
gold and silver makes sense for you that
comprehensive 16-page kit it reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
to get that kit text been - for seven
four seven four seven again text been my
name - 47 47 47 been - 47 47 47 alright
so the latest updates on Jesse Smollett
just breaking today apparently producers
of Empire finally have said that his
character will be removed from the final
two episodes of the latest season of
empire hilariously they had not said
this as of last night he was actually
headed back to the set of Empire in
Chicago following his release from
police custody on Thursday
Smollett was released after posting bail
in Chicago after police charged him with
staging what was originally reported as
a hate crime last month
he was originally intended to film
throughout the week on the Fox series
his role was dramatically reduced in
light of his ongoing legal troubles the
fact that he was even allowed to go back
to the set is perfectly insane and he
was involved in the worst race hoax
since Tawana Brown
in the United States and the guy is was
allowed to go back to set and what was
going through Fox's brain Fox has stood
behind the actor for the most part
issuing multiple statements backing him
as evidence grew that he had staged his
own assault this is variety reporting
earlier on Thursday though the network
released a new statement that said in
part we are evaluating the situation we
are considering our options
even with his mounting legal troubles
variety said smell it had big pockets of
support within Fox how is that even
possible
how's it possible to have large pockets
of support with the company after you
basically are caught signing checks to
two guys to fake a racial crime there
was hope as late as Wednesday he'll be
able to finish out his work on the
series Empire had about an episode and a
half of filming to finish his fifth
season or a little more than a week
worth of work apparently if instead they
are finally going to write him out they
released him on $100,000 bond and it's
just amazing to me
the level to which people will surrender
to their own narrative bias that to
return this guy to sort of civil society
even to consider returning this guy to
civil society in the midst of an ongoing
legal trial after presumably expending
hundreds of thousands of taxpayer
dollars on a racial hoax is just insane
you know you've done something wrong you
know that you've gone off the rails when
rahm emanuel a lefty of lefties is very
very upset with you because of your race
no here's rahm emanuel the mayor of
chicago and you'll recall the chief of
staff to barack obama talking to Don
Lemon
Kwasi reporter and friend of justice
Millette last night on CNN across our
city in 77 different neighborhoods there
are people that have signs in their
front lawn on their windows that say
Heath has no home here and to use
Chicago in that way is not true to who
we are as a city our police officers
took this as a very serious fake crime
and they dedicated the resources to deal
with it as a hate crime but then you
literally put doubt what about the young
man who is dealing with his own sexual
orientation and is attacked poured in
high school or at some school who's now
going to doubt whether people are going
to believe him you have put all those
real stories at risk for your fake story
that is not right there's certain irony
to Rahm Emanuel suggesting the justice
Millette story did grave damage for the
city of Chicago it did of course do
grave damage to the city of Chicago the
widespread perception that Chicago PD
are somehow racist that they were not
pursuing the case with alacrity or that
Chicago is home to tremendous amounts of
evil Magda racists who are running
around throughout the city trying to
string up black people
it's funny how so many folks on the Left
including rahm emanuel will say you know
this is a slander on the city of chicago
and it's land around the police
department and yet rahm emanuel barack
obama they were constantly slandering a
huge swath of americans as exactly the
kind of people that jesse smollett was
trying to target the entire justice
Millette routine was not really
targeting the city of chicago obviously
it was targeting President Trump it was
targeting white folks across the United
States who may have voted for President
Trump that was the goal of Jesse Smuts
routine he knew that folks like Rahm
Emanuel if the crime had been true he
knew that people like Rahm Emanuel would
have jumped on board the idea that there
were a huge swath of Americans who
agreed with the attackers the fake
attackers of Jesse Smollett so if Rahm
Emanuel is very concerned about stories
that draw a false conclusion about
fellow Americans then it seems to me
that people on the Left who might want
to reconsider how they treat crimes like
this in the future because the fact is
during the Obama administration Barack
Obama was complicit in presenting
exactly exactly the same types of
slander about certain parts of America
Barack Obama said about Ferguson
Missouri Michael Brown you'll recall was
an eighteen year old black man who
attacked a police officer he tried to
run at a police officer and was shot to
death for his trouble after robbing a
convenience store and after punching
that police officer in fit in the face
and that was portrayed by the media as
hands up don't shoot
remember anchors on CNN raising their
hands and posing for pictures hands up
don't shoot and remember Barack Obama in
the aftermath of the acquittal of the
officer in that particular case you'll
remember the President of the United
States getting on TV and expressing his
quazy sorrow at the verdict and then
suggesting that communities of color
don't make these things up that case was
made up that case was a race hoax that
case was a massive race hoax but we
don't see it that way why because
massive mainstream institutions decided
to
the race hoax so here's the point if you
are upset with Jessie Samoa on the Left
today because you feel that he slandered
the city of Chicago and the Chicago PD
and they made it harder for future
victims then you should have been just
as upset over the Michael Brown scenario
you should have been just as upset over
that you should have been just as upset
over other issues that were happening
like that during the Obama
administration people were not because
President Obama decided to back to play
in this particular case it blew back on
the city of Chicago so now the left
realizes that this sort of thing is bad
when it blows back on the state of
Missouri or the city of Ferguson then
it's completely different story pretty
amazing stuff by the way Jesse's moet
still has his defenders he has his
defenders on the grounds the president
Trump is bad now president Trump is
basically a get-out-of-jail-free card
for a lot of folks on the Left who don't
want to acknowledge that something
really truly terrible happened right
here DL Hughley alleged comedian was on
CNN with block of wood Chris Cuomo and
he was talking about
jussie Smollett he said well you know
Jesse Smollett shouldn't go to jail
president Trump isn't in jail well
that's because President Trump didn't
claim falsely that he was beaten half to
death and then called racial slurs by
people he had hired that that's why
President Trump isn't in jail DL Hughley
and his hat don't seem to understand
that you know it's interesting when you
when you use hatred and bigotry and
lying for your own self is handing your
young black kid young black a black kid
you get indicted if you do it when
you're a white guy you become president
and I think there are enough monsters
out there for real that we don't them
making yet white supremacists has never
had a historical high just it's
interesting the president would focus
more on the on the kid that that
orchestrated a fake attack but not the
man white supremacist who was
orchestrating an actual attack how
exactly is this on national news really
like how is this on CNN
what does DL Hughley saying here that is
any value whatsoever he's saying a
couple of things and neither of them
make any sense the first thing he says
is that if you use racism for your own
personal ends and you're black you go to
jail no actually if you use racism and
politics to your own personal ends you
end up getting elected to high office as
well it turns out that race baiting on
every side is very lucrative business
that's why Jesse somewhat tried to hoax
the reason Jesse somewhat tried this
routine is became because he knew there
was power in race baiting for personal
gain
arctan is still meeting with people
after helping perpetrate the Tawana
Brawley hoax and it's 35 years later so
DL Hughley is just wrong about this the
reason justice Millette is going to jail
is because he actually took up police
resources by reporting a fake hate crime
if Jesse Smollett had just gone out
there and preached about how America is
racist and how white people broadly
speaking are racist he'd be on the cover
of Time magazine next week he'd be
getting multi-million dollar deals like
Colin Kaepernick so DL Hughley is just
wrong about that and then when DL
Hughley
continues to suggest that white
supremacism is it a is it an all-time
high in the United States you know
ignorant you have to be of American
history to put leave that a truly
ignorant of American history an all-time
high
we had a literal war in this country
where half a million people died because
it seems like probably when there were
actual slaves being held in the United
States probably then is when white
supremacy was at its height if I had to
guess I'd probably peg it right then and
then you know when it was also really
high it was also really high when we had
a legal system of discrimination against
black people that was promoted
throughout the south and enshrined in
law up until the mid 60s that seems like
a time when white supremacism was at its
all-time high you know when it's not at
its all-time high in a country that
three years ago a black man was
President of the United States the
Attorney General of the United States
was a black man the Secretary of State
the Secretary of State Susan Rice was a
woman of color I mean what what what the
attempt to paint America is deeply
racist in spite of justice Millette
is amazing the real point here is the
one that masked wall Matt Walsh a
columnist over his daily wire made
yesterday which is that the supply of
racism of the United States is being
exceeded by demand there's too much
demand for racism and not enough supply
so now we have to get mad over silly
things or we have to make up race hoaxes
we have to we have to find every
instance of quasi or fake racism we can
in order to promote the idea that
America is still a terrible awful no
good very bad place it's it's pretty
astonishing I mean that that really is
the theme for justice Millette right all
Josie smell that had to do if he wanted
to be the leader on hate crimes against
black folks is fine a black gay person
who was victimized in a hate crime and
promote their story that's all he had to
do but he couldn't do that instead he
had to fake a hate crime so that we
could make the front pages across the
United States it's pretty astonishing
and by the way again there's still
people gonna defend justice Millette
because they are going to make the claim
that justice Millette is indicative of a
broader problem even if his story is
fake the story is fake but the moral is
real the aoc version of politics we'll
get to more of that in just a second
first there's one thing we can all agree
on no matter what we disagree on it's
good to save money and this is why you
ought to be using honey you've probably
heard me talk about honey it's an
amazing free browser extension that
automatically helps me save money on all
my favorite sites but I would not be
doing my job if I didn't tell you how
honey makes even Amazon better I love
Amazon Amazon's the best and I save
money on Amazon every single day because
as you shop on Amazon
honey's best price finder automatically
compares the prices of millions of
sellers that carry the item that you
want honey even factors in shipping
sales tax and Amazon Prime status to
make sure that you're getting the lowest
total price it shows you the best deal
every time even if Amazon doesn't it's
like having your very own smart shopping
assistant I saved a bunch of money this
week my wife has finally started working
out a lot on a regular basis and she
wanted to buy some weights one on Amazon
bought some weights
honey kicked in we saved a bunch of
money more than 10 million people are
using honey to save money right now
honey has over a hundred thousand
five-star reviews on the Google Chrome
store Time magazine says it's basically
free money that's because it is so next
time you're shopping on Amazon treat
yourself to the free upgrade that
guarantees you always get the best
absolute price add honey for free at
join honey calm slash Ben that's join
honey calm slash Ben honey the smart
shopping assistant that helps you save
time and money alright so there's still
people who are in fact race hoax
specialists or at least racialist
who make Bank off this stuff who refuse
to acknowledge the justice Millette even
did anything wrong one of those people
is auntie Maxine who has been promoted
as a champion of the downtrodden among
the Democratic Party especially now
because she's very anti Trump she said
yesterday she still doesn't believe the
Chicago PD how do we make sense of
justice Millette
how do we make sense of the situation I
don't think we can at this point it
makes sense of it there's still some
questions that we have some answers that
have to be given he's a friend and so
III believed him
when I heard about it I still don't know
all of the details I'm waiting for the
final results of
all of this if in fact this to hoax of
course I would be disappointed oh if
it's a hoax you'd be disappointed he's
been arrested they've a sighing check
from him to the people he was paying to
promote the hoax they have the phone
call log in which he was calling the
guys who helped him promote the hoax the
evidence is pretty damn clear right here
and Maxine Waters is still pretending
that the evidence isn't fully in it
really is amazing Kamala Harris is doing
a little bit of the same routine so
you'll recall that Kamala Harris first
said that this was a modern day lynching
and then you'll recall that Kamala
Harris said that she was going to wait
for all the facts to come out while
pretending that she didn't actually know
what the facts were and now she has
released a statement it says like most
of you I've seen the reports about Jesse
Smollett and I'm sad frustrated and
disappointed when anyone makes false
claims to police it not only diverts
resources away from serious
investigations but it makes it more
difficult for other victims of crime to
come forward at the same time we must
speak the truth hate crimes are on the
rise in America just last year the FBI
released statistics that revealed a 17
percent increase in the number of hate
crimes in America part of the tragedy of
the situation is that it distracts from
that truth and has been seized by some
who would like to dismiss and downplay
the very real problems that we must
address we should not allow that so the
real problem is not really Jesse smut
the real problem is people seizing and
pouncing oh like a tiger on jussie
Smollett you know and then the real the
real good knows here I guess is that he
raised awareness in the end he raised
awareness of of hate crimes that's
that's the real thing that we should be
very excited about her Lena Maxwell
another commentator doing this this
justice Millette defense routine pretty
amazing over on MSNBC she says listen we
should react to Jesse Schmo up with
empathy
you know empathy for the guy who was
willing to falsely testify that people
who did not commit a crime committed a
crime and send them to jail presumably
for the rest of their lives
we should have empathy for that guy
folks that believe Jesse as a default
position we feel sadness today we don't
feel stupid today I feel bad for the
people who did not default to that
empathy who think that this is a game
who are gloating today those people have
something fundamentally wrong with them
the people that defaulted to feeling
empathy for someone who may have you
know who may be going through something
so I still feel empathy for him because
obviously he's deeply troubled
but I think we should default to
supporting people and let the
investigators do the investigation oh so
so so I guess that you're a good person
if you believed him without evidence but
you're a bad person if you are happy
that the police uncovered the fact that
his crazy story was actually a crazy
story by the way we have no evidence
that he's actually a mentally ill
remember any evidence that Jesse
Smollett is mentally ill I've said this
before
you can't just attribute crazy to things
you don't understand Jesse's Mallette
took action he did that as an
independent human that is his decision
this notion that we are supposed to
default to empathy after it's already
revealed that this piece of debris I
mean he's a bad guy that is a bad guy
somebody who is willing to testify
falsely so that other people go to jail
that makes you a bad human being Jesse
Smith did something deeply evil here and
pretend that empathy should be on the
table is bizarre at best and obviously
malicious at worst because you're
actually promoting a narrative not a
truth and meanwhile there was an actual
political crime a politically driven
assault that happened at Berkeley I
guess this was yesterday and police at
Berkeley were called to a student plaza
on Tuesday after reports that a
representative of the conservative
Leadership Institute was physically
assaulted by a man on the campus well we
actually have tape of it and here is
what it sounded like you are encouraging
violence no I'm not so he punished the
who plunged the student in the I gave
him a black eye the student the student
maintained control of the camera so we
have a good shot of guys days I mean
just delivered a short right to his to
his eye and this guy should be arrested
and obviously he will be arrested he's
now on camera so the chances that he
doesn't end up spending some time in
jail pretty low The Daily Californian
was the first outlet to report the
incident which the student-run paper
says took place in the upper Sproul
Plaza setting a campus palete alert
police alert that went out Wednesday the
paper reports that the alleged victim a
male Leadership Institute representative
had been tabling for turning-point us as
Charlie Kirk's group on Tuesday
afternoon
3:29 p.m. when two males approached the
table the victim told police he and the
two men became embroiled in a verbal
altercation at which point he began
filming the escalating exchange with his
phone one of the two attack alleged
attackers reportedly slapped the phone
out of the act of his hand and then
overturned the table the recruit the
group was using to recruit well he and
the suspect struggled for the phone the
suspect punched the victim several times
causing injury to the victims eye and
nose by the time the police arrived the
suspect had already left the scene a
student who witnessed the attack filmed
the second part of the altercation on
his on his phone Charlie Kirk the head
of T P USA tweeted out the footage wrote
imagine if the attacker was wearing a
mag a hat would be national news that of
course is 100% true that is 100% true
the college fix has also published
additional footage filmed by a
conservative activist that includes the
assaulter threatening I'll shoot your
bleep so the Student Paper has reported
in an update that UC Berkeley Chancellor
Carol Crist said in a statement the
campus condemns all forms of harassment
and violence is that and that the
university does not have any information
about whether the student but the
suspect is a student at the University
he is wearing a backpack and he appears
to be college-age the student who
reportedly filmed the incident
apparently told Breitbart news that the
altercation appears to begun over an
argument about a tipi us a sign that
warned hate crime hoaxes hurt real
victims which was a reference to justice
Millette
and then apparently he began filming
after the suspect flipped over the table
newsweek covering this thing newsweek
headline conservative activists
allegedly allegedly assaulted when they
headlined to justice Millette it was
just east moet assaulted you be the you
be the judge as to whether the media
would be covering this differently if
this had been an Obama supporter punched
by a trump supporter I have a feeling
the answer would be yes it meanwhile in
a horrifying story this is from the
Washington Post
a judge has now ruled that prosecutorial
deal a prosecutorial deal between labor
secretary Alexander Acosta and Jeffrey
Epstein's lawyers was absolutely corrupt
which is 100% true we covered this a few
months ago on the podcast a judge ruled
Thursday that federal prosecutors
including the future labor secretary
Alexander Acosta violated the law when
they did not tell victims the government
had struck a deal not to prosecute
Jeffrey Epstein a politically connected
bill
accused of molesting dozens of young
girls you'll recall Jeffrey Epstein from
having an island it was basically sex
slave island he had a bunch of underage
young girls there and he was flying his
friends down there and his friends
ranged in politics from Bill Clinton to
I believe he was friendly with Trump I
think I know that he was friendly with
Alan Dershowitz the ruling was a
stinging rebuke for prosecutors and how
they behaved in a grim high-profile case
that has drawn increased scrutiny in
recent months a Miami Herald
investigation last year highlighted the
allegations an Acosta's role in cutting
a non-prosecution agreement with Epstein
well a Justice Department office said it
is exploring whether the federal
prosecutors who reached the deal
committed professional misconduct
District Judge Kenneth Mara was blunt
ruling the prosecutors had acted
improperly in reaching the agreement
with Epstein which stopped federal
action in exchange for him pleading
guilty to a state charge without telling
the victims I mean the case itself was
horrific
he was basically kidnapping young girls
off the street bringing them home and
then have it and then sexually abusing
them and then he was releasing them
because he was extraordinarily wealthy
and because he gave lots of money to
politicians the presumption is that this
had an impact on how his prosecution
went the judge wrote that he was not
ruling the decision not to prosecute was
improper he was simply ruling that under
the facts of this case there was a
violation of the victims rights under
the CVRA which is the crime victims
rights act which entitles victims to
know about significant events in their
cases prosecutors did not give victims a
chance to effect prosecutorial decisions
and did not accurately tell them about
what was happening prosecutors instead
sought to conceal the existence of the
deal cut with Epstein and mislead the
victims to believe that federal
prosecution was still a possibility mara
wrote while the government spent untold
hours negotiating the terms and
implications of the nonprofit
prosecution agreements with Epstein's
attorney scant information was shared
with the victims the case remains in
active litigation it has referred
further questions to the Justice
Department the US Attorney's Office in
Southern District of Florida declined to
comment on the ruling the allegations
against Epstein and the fact that he had
reached a deal had been publicly known
they came up during a cost as 2017
confirmation hearings to leave the Labor
Department the case surged back into the
public eye in November when the herald
published its investigation reporting it
had identified approximately 80 women
who said they had been sexually abused
by Epstein between
2001 and 2006 and then how Epstein had
struck a deal that effectively ended an
FBI probe the Justice Department
revealed earlier this month it had
opened an investigation into how
prosecutors hadn't handled the Epstein
case that the probe is likely to be of
limited impact Epstein is one of the
worst people walking this earth I mean
just one of the worst people and the
fact that he was politically connected I
can't imagine that had nothing to do
with the agreement that was cut here I
imagine they were probably powerful
people or sounding off to the
prosecution office about letting Epstein
go when people talk about in justices in
the criminal justice system I think it
has very little to do with race I think
it has a lot to do with the amount of
power that you wield and if you're
Jeffrey Epstein and you're paying off
politicians and those politicians can
call up their political friends
sometimes deals get cut that way and
that is really bad there's a reason that
it's good to be a celebrity in a
criminal justice case it is not good to
be a non-celebrity we will see what
happens with Jesse smart by the way hey
there's a report yesterday that it is
likely that the prosecution will kind of
deal with Smollett so he does no jail
time which would be fully insane at
least on the state level we'll see what
the feds do bottom line here is that if
a cost had cut this deal for any corrupt
reason at all not only should he not be
labor secretary he should probably do
jail time I mean that's that that's an
insane deal to cut that you're going to
let the guy off without prosecution for
abusing underage girls for years on end
very very frightening and bad look for a
criminal justice system obviously I'm
going to get to voter fraud in just a
second because voter fraud is back in
the news this time it's in the news
because Republicans were engaged in it
we'll talk about it in just a second
first let's talk about your postage
rates they've gone up again thankfully
stamps calm can ease the pain with big
discounts off post office retail rates
with stamps calm you save five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail that kind of savings
really does add up especially for small
businesses stamps calm is completely
online which saves you time no more
inconvenient trips to the post office
stamps come automatically calculates and
prints the exact amounts of postage you
need for every letter or package you
send you're never going to overpay or
under pay again stamps.com brings all
the services of the US Postal Service
directly to your fingertips buy and
print official US postage for any letter
any package any class of mail using your
own computer and printer stamps.com
makes it easy they'll send you
free digital scale automatically
calculating your exact postage anything
you can do at the post office you can
now do from your desk for less that's
why I use stamps calm it saves me time
it saves me money it means I don't have
to schlep my packages down to the post
office right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage ends digital
scale see for yourself why over 700
thousand small businesses use stamps com
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro that is stamps com
enter Shapiro for that special deal
stamps icon click on that mic at the top
of the homepage type in Shapiro
alrighty meanwhile a new election has
been ordered in North Carolina according
to the New York Times North Carolina
officials on Thursday ordered a new
contest in the ninth congressional
district after the Republican candidate
confronted by evidence that his campaign
had financed an illegal voter turnout
effort called for a new election the
unanimous ruling by the five-member
Board of Elections was a startling and
for Republicans embarrassing conclusion
to a case that has convulsed North
Carolina since November and it followed
testimony that outlined how a political
operative had orchestrated an absentee
ballot scheme to try to sway the race in
favor of Mark Harris the Republican
candidate it is now the single undecided
house contest in last year's at midterms
Robert Cordell the state's Board
Chairman cited the corruption absolute
mess with the absentee ballots when he
called for a new election he said it was
certainly tainted Harris had a 905 vote
lead over his Democratic opponent Dan
McReady but his success in Bladen County
where he won 61% of the absentee ballots
even though Republicans were there
accounted for just 19% of them alarmed
regulators when he finally took the
stand on Thursday morning mr. Harris
denied knowing of any wrongdoing in the
voter turnout effort led by Elle McRae
Dallas jr. a veteran political operative
known as a local guru of elections but
in a series of questions Harris stumbled
and appeared to mislead the board when
he returned to the crowded courtroom
after lunch recess he asked whether he
could read a statement he apologized to
the board
he explained that recent medical issues
including two strokes had impaired his
abilities and recall and then he asked
for a new election which sounds pretty
damaging to him now the entire article
talks about this this voter operations
guy McCray Dallas and it talks about his
history in the district but it does not
actually talk until very late about his
long time history working for dumb
Kratts in fact if you search the piece
for references to Democrat there is no
there's one reference one reference to
his shadowy work for Democratic and
Republican politicians but that is not
how New York Times reporter Patrick
Healy talked about this on CNN and
here's Patrick Healy the politics editor
for the New York Times saying
Republicans are engaging in voter fraud
for years president Trump and
Republicans have tried to create this
image that Democrats were stealing
elections the Democrats phony votes you
know President Trump would have won the
popular vote against Hillary Clinton if
not for all of this voter fraud by
Democrats never proven no evidence and
now the Republicans have the biggest
case of voter fraud that we've had in
this country for years
okay amazing I will point out it is
amazing that the politics editor of The
New York Times will say the Republicans
are responsible for voter fraud let's
learn a little bit about Leslie McCray
Dallas now it is true in this case
Republicans apparently responsible for
voter fraud obviously that is true also
true this guy has been working for
politicians of both parties and mostly
the Democratic Party over the course of
his career according to the news
observer in North Carolina Dallas had
long voted in Democratic primaries but
became a registered Republican after the
2016 general election in 2012 he was
paid for get-out-the-vote efforts for
competing Democratic candidates in a
State House race why we're do you think
maybe a voter fraud guru may have
committed voter fraud on behalf of
Democrats historically but nobody cared
because it was Democrats doing it in a
Democratic primary news reports indicate
he has been doing campaign work at least
as far back as 2006 he told the news
reporter of Whiteville in a 2010 article
that he worked on then district attorney
rex Gore's campaign that year in 2010
Dallas worked for the man gore defeated
Harold butch Pope a Whiteville attorney
during that campaign Pope in Dallas has
respond to concerns about Dallas's
criminal record in 1992 Dallas was
convicted of felony insurance fraud
after he and his wife were accused of
taking out an insurance policy on a dead
man and collecting nearly a hundred and
sixty-five thousand dollars from his
death and he's being hired by Democrats
for years after that he served more than
six months of a two-year prison sentence
after after repeating the plot of Double
Indemnity Pope knocked out gore in the
Democratic primary then lost the
to John David who remains the district
attorney for Bladen Brunswick and
Columbus counties Pope said when he ran
for the office two or three people
called and told him he needed to Dallas
working for him in Bladen County
someone told me McCray Dallas is the
Guru of Bladen County so the guy who is
responsible for the voter fraud this
McCray Dallas fellow he basically was
gathering absentee ballots and then he
was throwing out the ones that he didn't
like and he was keeping the ones that he
did like that was essentially what
happened here and this is why ballot
gathering is a bad process absentee
ballots should not be allowed unless
you're a member of the military really
absentee ballots early voting it should
only be allowed if you'll remember the
military this idea that we need to
maximize the number of people voting
early and then we need to allow various
political parties to go out and vote
gather is extraordinarily dangerous it's
extraordinarily dangerous and yet
Democrats don't seem to have any problem
with the with the systematic voter fraud
issue this is the part that I think
Republicans have a real claim on and
Democrats are pointing to this case and
saying look voter fraud and I'm like yes
of course voter fraud yes that's voter
fraud that's very bad you know it's bad
when everyone does it maybe we should
change the system so it is not as easy
to commit voter fraud take for example
my state California the San Diego
union-tribune has a piece back from
December it says this in the wake of
last month's blue wave the wrested
control of the house from Republicans
and transferred it to the Democratic
Party some members of the GOP are
complaining about the results and the
practice of so-called ballot harvesting
in California House Speaker Paul Ryan is
then the House speaker said last week
the California defies logic and he can't
begin to understand what ballot
harvesting is so what exactly is ballot
harvesting it's political jargon for a
practice in which organized workers or
volunteers collect absentee ballots from
certain voters and drop them off at a
polling place or election office coined
by California Republicans that the term
carries a negative connotation to
suggest improprieties and even election
fraud in 2016 Jerry Brown signed into
law a change to section 30 17 of the
election code that allows any person to
collect a mail-in ballot from voters and
turn in the mail ballot to a polling
place or the Registrar's Office prior
law restricted the practice to just
relatives or those living in the same
household as the voter so in other words
Jerry Brown made voter fraud easier
cuz now you could have somebody just
coming to your door and saying listen I
I've been assigned by whomever I've been
assigned by the elections Oversight
Committee to to come gather your ballot
so you know you're not gonna leave it in
the mail you're gonna forget just give
me your ballot just vote right now give
me your ballot I'll take it down to the
mailbox for you I'm not sure that this
said that the actual law requires you to
say if you are working from one of the
parties and the legislation says that a
vote by a male voter who has an unable
to return the ballot may designate any
person to return the ballot to the
elections official from whom it came or
to the precinct board at a polling place
within the jurisdiction so in other
words the actual process that McRae
Dallas used which is he would go around
gather a bunch of ballots throw out the
ones he didn't like keep the ones he did
like that process is very much on the
table in places like California and was
just made easier by the former Governor
of California Jerry Brown it used to be
you can only give it to your brother or
sister or your wife your kids take the
ballot down the mailbox and drop it off
now it's if I come to your door and I
sign a piece of paper saying I gave you
my ballot then I can hand it to Rando
and who the hell knows what Rando is
doing with those ballots so this is
where I have a real problem with all the
talk about voter fraud if you're only
concerned about voter fraud when it
happens on one side of the aisle you are
not really concerned about voter fraud
if you are only upset about voter fraud
because of what just happened in North
Carolina's ninth district but you don't
care that the guy who responsible for
the voter fraud was active in elections
for legitimately 4 election cycles
before that I don't care that the exact
methodology he used is still open to
abuse in states like California then you
don't get to claim that you're that you
really care about voter fraud all you
care about is blaming Republicans that's
why that politics editor from The New
York Times is doing a grave disservice
to the actual issue now I love this the
San Diego union-tribune says there have
been no credible reports of ballot
harvesting being employed illegally or
systematically to amount to election
fraud Secretary of State Alex Padilla
was quoted saying the laws don't benefit
one party over another oh well we're not
gonna find out about that until it's
found out about that's the thing about
crimes you don't find out about them
until somebody detects the crime and
again don't pretend that you care about
this stuff unless you actually care
about this stuff it's just absurd
okay in a second we're going to talk
about
the Democrats who continue to move
evermore to the left first let's talk
about how you shave each morning hey get
ready the kind of soap you use I love
the Dollar Shave Club has everything I
need to look feel and smell my best what
I love even more is the fact that I
never have to go to a store that's
because number one es he delivers
everything I need directly to my door
and two they keep me fully stocked on
what I use so I don't run out here's how
it works
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you are
getting ready for they've got you
covered head to toe for your hair your
skin your face you name it they've got
it and they have a new program when they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use you determine what you
want and when you want it it shows up
right at your door from once a month so
once every six months that's what I do
for their amber lavender body cleanser
there's sage black pepper shampoo I mean
it's fantastic plus with their handsome
discount the more you buy the more you
save
and right now they've got a bunch of
starter sets you can try for just five
bucks like their oral care kit after
that the restock box trips regular sized
products at regular price so what
exactly are you waiting for get your
starter set for just five bucks right
now at dollarshaveclub.com
slash pen that is dollarshaveclub.com
slash pen there's a reason I use their
products it's because they're awesome
dollarshaveclub.com slash men for the
special deal go check it out right now
okay so the Democrats continue to move
in more and more radical directions the
latest indicator of this is Elizabeth
Warren calling for I kid you not slavery
reparations this will be a mainstream
Democratic position across the board the
first person to talk about it was Kamala
Harris and the reason that she agreed
with it is because a host suggested it
to her so now we are making policy by
radio host suggestions which aim if
we're gonna do that I'm right here guys
I'm right here we'll get to all that in
just a second first first you have to
subscribe over at daily wire today for
example we are featuring a daily wire
premium subscriber we wanted to give a
shout out to a different subscriber
every week as a thank you for helping
support the daily wire although let's be
honest we're already giving you people
way more than you deserve that's true we
are this week's shout out goes to
Cameron at real mcg cam on Twitter
Cameron tweeted this epic photo of him
inhaling what I'm guessing is scalding
hot left his tears because judging by
the photo Cameron total badass dude
Cameron writes because ben shapiro told
me to do it hot or cold tumblr near
Leavenworth Washington from Seattle they
look at that
Sonoma BL trees cold outside that's
man's stuff if you want to receive a
shout out and experience the pure bliss
the Cameron is likely experiencing at
this very instant you have to be an
annual subscriber and you have to post a
photo of your tumbler on either twitter
or instagram with the hashtag leftist
tears tumblr you can even be in the
photo if you would like get creative
folks keep it keep it PG rated we like
when you make us laugh and entertain me
I mean I entertain you come on also be
sure to join us at this Monday February
25th for the daily wire backstage where
we will be talking about everyone's
favorite award show that which I mean
the one no one's gonna watch but wall
watch the highlights daily wired
god-king jeremy boring me andrew Clavin
the execrable michael knowles and alicia
Kraus will be here talking culture
Hollywood and of course taking our
questions as well
as always only daily where subscribers
get to ask those questions so make sure
to subscribe today also as we mentioned
when you subscribe you get to ask me
questions in the mailbag which we will
be doing momentarily and the annual
subscription comes with that leftist
tears tumblr which as you have seen is
so magnificent that it will warm your
bones even in the chilliest of days in
Leavenworth Washington so go check that
out right now we have so much good stuff
free I mean like two additional hours of
the show every day later today we also
have the sunday special which is
available as a Saturday special for
people who subscribe I mean this is a
hell of a pitch guys I'm spending a lot
of time and effort on it so all I can
say is you should really go get a
subscription just do it guys okay so we
always appreciate your business
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so back to the Democratic move toward
the radical left the new platform for a
lot of the Democrats is apparently gonna
be slavery reparations now you may you
may be thinking I know what you're
thinking what you're thinking is isn't
it 2019 doesn't that mean that it's been
approximately a hundred and fifty three
years since the end of slavery in the
United States why are we talking about
slavery reparations that would be a good
question the answer is because there's a
group of Democrats who have to pander
for a percentage of the Democratic
voting base in the primaries it's that
simple because guess what is they think
that's not going to happen that you know
why it's not gonna happen because it is
utterly impractical it is utterly
impractical and by the way
counterproductive because it is it is
suggesting that the vast majority of
disparities in mobility in today's
American society are due to an event
that ended a hundred and fifty years ago
that does not hold water it does not if
you want to say that people who suffered
under Jim Crow should get some sort of
reparations from the state of Alabama
for example there is maybe an argument
those people are still living but if you
want to suggest that people ought to get
slavery reparations that's a different
story also here's the question how would
you even do that who pays it and who
receives it so for example barack obama
half black half white this is white half
play reparations for as black half how
does that work exactly now if you are
one quarter black do you get slavery
reparations also if you are black but
not a descendant of a slave if you're a
common-law harris and your father is
jamaican your mama's indian do you get
slavery reparations i assume not also
shouldn't we make it so that the people
who directly benefited from slavery are
the ones who foot the bill for it or are
we gonna make the people who are
descendants of people who died in the
civil war fighting slavery pay for the
reparations and one of the broad-based
accusations when it comes to slavery and
Jim Crow is that the entire United
States benefited as a whole from slavery
and Jim Crow that is obviously an
eminently economically untrue it is just
not true
there is no fact pattern that suggests
whatsoever that the vast majority of
white people who are not directly
engaged in having slaves on their
plantation benefited from slavery in
fact it helped make the southern economy
agrarian and backwards the reason that
the north overwhelmed the south was
sheer industrial power and a large part
of that is because slavery was not
allowed in the north slavery
is not actually economically feasible or
beneficial and forget that it's morally
evil it is not it is not feasible or
economically beneficial so the entire
basis of reparations which is the United
States broad-scale benefited from
slavery and the white people in the
United States broad-scale benefited from
slavery that is simply not true and the
reason that matters is because for my
family my great-great grandparents
arrived in the United States in like
1907 that was a solid sic that that was
solid 50 years after the end of slavery
in the United States that were Jewish
they lived in New York when they first
got here
should they be paying slavery
reparations well the theory is that they
lived in a system that had benefited
from slavery therefore they should pay
slavery reparations but they moved into
that system fifty years after slavery
ended and you're gonna have you're gonna
be hard pressed to tell me how my great
great grandparents benefited from
slavery like really you're gonna have to
explain that one to me it doesn't make
any sense whatsoever the best you could
do if you're just talking about a
fairness argument if you're talking
about a simple racial fairness argument
is find the descent the direct
descendants of slaves find the direct
descendants of plantation owners and
have the direct descendants of
plantation owners turn over a percentage
of their wealth to the direct
descendants of slaves that's going to be
very difficult and also it's likely not
to be beneficial because there's a very
good shot that many of the people who
are direct descendants of plantation
owners are poorer than the direct
descendants of slaves and once you are
far removed from historical events
making it right through reparations is
extraordinarily difficult as I say I
think there if you if someone could make
a case about Jim Crow maybe maybe you
know Holocaust reparations make some
sense to me because those people are
still living and the German government
was responsible
so maybe but the idea that we're gonna
go to slavery reparations now obviously
it's just a pandering move especially by
Elizabeth Warren
so Kamala Harris was on a radio show and
she was asked about government
reparations for black Americans and she
said if that was necessary to address
the slate of the legacy of slavery and
discrimination she affirmed that
statement she said we have to be honest
that people in this country do not start
from the same place or have access to
the same opportunities I'm serious about
taking an approach that would change
policies and structures that make real
investment in black communities well
that's not slavery reparations
presumably that was a large part of what
drove the social welfare state
LBJ essentially said that openly that he
saw large swaths of the the social
welfare state as designed - as designed
to address the disparities that existed
between black and whites in the United
States on economic issues Elizabeth
Warren also said she supported
reparations for black Americans because
she's basically just following around
every candidate and shouting yeah me too
her campaign is she follows around
Kamala Harris until khamel Harris said
something radical and then Elizabeth
Warren stands in the background wage
yeah I also agree and then Bernie
Sanders emerges from the woodwork SiC I
think that everything should be free and
Elizabeth Warren creeps up behind him
pops up her pen shows yeah me too
that's basically her campaign at this
point I love this the Warren campaign
declines to give further details on that
backing but it came amid her calls for
the federal government to provide
special home buying assistance to
residents of communities that were
adversely affected by redlining so
here's the other problem what you're
seeing from a lot of Democrats is an
attempt to push bad government policy
not direct reparations actual bad
government policy that has resulted in
terrible economic woes for the United
States on the basis that disparity is
discrimination so too few black families
were getting home loans therefore why
don't we have a subprime mortgage
industry backed by the federal
government that won't do any harm will
it except for you know destroying half
the United States economy in 2007-2008
except for that it'll be totally fine
pursuing bad policy as some form of
reparations is not smart either for
black people or for white people and if
we are talking about reparations we have
to discuss who gets it from when from
whom over what period and why okay you
know let's do a little bit of mailbag
here so John says what are your thoughts
on Andrew gangs running for president
2020 on the Democratic ticket 1,000
month ubi freedom dividend that he
proposes can be available for all
Americans to either replace or enhance
welfare well III believe that the only
purpose of a universal basic income or
negative income tax is Milton Friedman
suggested is if you're going to replace
the entire welfare structure with it if
basically we just sign a cheque to
everybody every month below a certain
income level and that's it there are no
other supplemental programs we don't
need seventy different welfare programs
we don't need food stamps we don't need
any of that stuff we just sign you a
check and now it's your job to do with
it what you will the problem I see is
that many of the
decisions that are being made with money
by people who are on welfare are not
great decisions in the first place so
that is not to suggest they shouldn't
have control over their money they
should but if you have control over your
money that means that you also bear the
brunt of the decisions that you make
with your money it's one of the reasons
why for example there's been a
suggestion by Republicans for health
savings accounts when it comes to health
care for poor people because there's a
fear that a lot of that money will not
be used for health savings will not be
used for health insurance and then there
will just be more draw on the public
treasury Keegan says howdy been recently
you commended a Mozart piece Piano
Concerto number one second movement and
I've absolutely fallen in love with it
consider me ignorant on classical
composers the earliest music in my
typical playlist is the big bands of the
early 1900s I have a love for swing
music what other composers or pieces
would you recommend well all Brahms
chamber music is fantastic I love his
piano quintet
I love his piano quartets then the first
piano quartet particularly I love his
his violin sonatas are wonderful I love
to play those as well in terms of
symphonies you got to take the Beethoven
symphonies usually people recommend the
odd numbers 3 5 7 to 9 those are all
fantastic number 6 is also great that's
the pastoral you'll have seen it in
Fantasia I'm a big fan of Dvorak so 9th
symphony the New World Symphony that
one's terrific if you like a more
dissonant music and more modern music
and Bartok's concerto for orchestra is
one of my personal favorites there's so
much great classical music everything
that mozart wrote in his late career is
I tend to love so I love Don Giovanni
I love the the Requiem at least the
parts of it that he wrote he died in the
middle of writing his Requiem there's so
much great classical music Mendelssohn's
Italian symphony his Scottish Symphony
his violin concerto so it really depends
on the form of music you're talking
about but that that's enough to get you
started also one of my personal
favorites I've played it on the show
before Ray Vaughan Williams his his
Fantasia on the theme by Thomas Tallis
is I think one of the most spiritual
pieces of music ever written Zachary
says I'm currently dating a girl from
Peru
who's blindsided by the fact that she
was illegal due her to her parents never
informing her until she was 18 we've
been fighting to keep her here via a
pardon and after a year she only
recently has been granted the permission
to get biometrics done my question is
two parts is it morally right to be
Republican and against illegal
immigration and still date her and how
could the system of immigration be sped
up while still having a proper
process thanks for all you do of course
it's morally right to be a Republican
and against illegal immigration and
still date this person of course I know
I don't see the conflict at all you're
not saying that you should continue to
illegally immigrate you're not saying
that you should continue to violate
America's laws and presumably if you
married her and she were rejected for
immigration status then you would find
another place to live so I don't see a
conflict there at all what I do see is a
system that is wildly broken when a lot
of people who were brought here as
children and our net benefits to the
United States it takes forever for them
to get citizenship but we're talking
blanket amnesty for people who come
across the border now that makes no
sense to me at all my wife was an
immigrant to the United States she came
here with her family permanently when
she was 12 she and her family are sort
of back and forth between Israel and the
United States for many years they moved
her permanently when she was 12 she
didn't get her citizenship until she was
23 and it was not because she married me
had already been married a couple of
years her green card finally ran and so
she had ten years in the United States
and then she got citizenship is that
what was that length of that process
truly necessary her dad had been working
at a major American company for years on
end
he had already gotten his citizenship so
what exactly was the holdup our
immigration system is broken and this is
just another indicator of it zakharik
says a co-worker and I often discuss
complex and larger issues about life the
state of the country etc one thing that
has recently come up that we can't seem
to figure out is automation and AI now
I'm not a big fan of you be I button 10
or so years when electric vehicles and
self-driving vehicles become more
prevalent retail stores and fast-food
restaurants become mostly automated
which causes millions of jobs to
evaporate and not all of those people
can be retrained to do something else do
you think will inevitably end up with a
ubi or do you think there's a better
solution
well again people are asking me to
predict the future on these sorts of
questions all I can say is that if the
future looks like the past the answer is
no if the future looks like the past and
technology will be an aid to the
creation of new jobs and new industries
and we can look at a number of examples
from modern American life first of all
150 years ago did we think there would
be a massive trucking industry no
because the car had not yet been
invented so it'd be very difficult to
imagine a giant trucking industry could
we imagine an entire social media
industry no the internet was invented
like 25 30 years ago or at least became
wide
at that point you know that we create
new jobs and new industries all the time
like the daily wire we have we're gonna
have probably 100 employees over the
next year
none of those jobs exist in the absence
of the internet or television none of
that exists how many people are in the
entertainment industry today that
entertainment industry did not exist in
other words with new technology come new
opportunities and the fact is the
technology very often is an aid to job
creation not a not a killer of jobs it
kills certain types of jobs always but
it also aids in the creation of new
types of jobs which tend to be by the
way easier and less back-breaking than
the old jobs I always find it kind of
weird when people like I long for the
days when my grandfather worked on a
Union line at Ford and he could afford a
house you know it's probably a really
bad job working on a Union line at Ford
really going into like 8:00 in the
morning coming home at 5:00 at night and
all you did was just rivet stuff all day
is that a job you would take and maybe
your grandfather thought it was a great
job at the time because that was the
kind of job that was around at the time
but would you rather sit on your fat can
in an office in an air-conditioned
office or would you prefer to be in a
hot sweltering Factory riveting stuff
ten hours a day for 35 years yeah I find
it kind of there's a certain level of
ingratitude in American life that is
really kind of galling to me visit this
in gratitude that suggests that we
really have it hard now it was better
how it used to be the very few aspects
of American life that are that are worse
than they used to be really maybe some
of our moral life but certainly not much
of our economic life Donny says can you
explain how illegal immigrants cost
America money I hear they pay all taxes
from some people and just sales tax from
others
well they don't pay income tax obviously
because their income is not reportable
they do pay sales tax they are a drain
on America's resources in terms of
public education if they have kids who
become citizens and are not eligible for
all sorts of government benefits also if
you just come here as an illegal
immigrant you are eligible for certain
state benefits you're not eligible for
any federal benefits but if you're an
illegal immigrant in the state of
California there are certain state
benefits that do accrue to you plus you
can be a drain on our emergency rooms
for example there's a big debate over
whether illegal immigration is of net
cost or net benefit to the United States
this statistics i've seen and tend to
believe are the ones that suggest it is
a net cost to the United States okay
let's see one more question one more
question David says hey Ben my wife and
I have
kids four of whom were adopted out of
the foster care adopting has been by far
the greatest decision in our lives
it has lately been on our hearts to have
another child and my wife and I can't
help but feel pain for every victim of
abortion I've done some searching on the
internet with no success do you know of
any agencies or groups that assist in
finding parents for children that would
otherwise have been aborted we know we
can't do much but we feel if we can give
one child a loving home that's a good
start thanks for all you do well thanks
for all you do I mean what you're doing
sounds a lot more important than what
I'm doing frankly that's an amazing
amazing thing I have nothing but
admiration for people who adopt it's an
incredible incredible thing so you know
as far as the agencies that do this
honestly they're a lot of Catholic
Charities that specifically are sort of
designed to reach out to folks who are
contemplating abortion also they're
pro-life pregnancy centers that you
should check out because many of those
recommend adoption rather than abortion
to women let's see
Ashley final question who do you think
will sit on the Iron Throne
now you've asked a question I care about
so this is a game of Thrones question so
if you're not a Game of Thrones fans
tough so who do I think will sit on the
Iron Throne here is how I think the last
season of Game of Thrones will go I
think that Daenerys has been set up for
too many seasons as the heroines who
actually be the heroine I think that she
was going to turn to the dark side and
she will go crazy like her like her
father did because everyone else in her
family has gone crazy maybe she'll have
a redeeming moment like a Darth Vader
moment where it seems like she's going
crazy and at the very end she stops
herself but Daenerys is certainly going
to die the chances of her surviving the
series are zero I'd be willing to put
money on this really I think Jon Snow
has already died so killing him off
would be anti-climactic I think he
probably survives I think there's about
a 50/50 shot that he's forced to kill
Daenerys especially since in the end of
last season they went at it so I have a
feeling that this is the way Game of
Thrones works I have a feeling he might
be the one who has to who has to kill
her I think that there's a very a very
good shot that well not a very good shot
a 100% shot that Jamie Lannister has to
kill Cersei so not Cersei not Daenerys
I think jon is going to have to recede
to the west he's been changed too much
by his death and his comeback it's gonna
be sort of like Frodo after throwing the
ring in the fire I think in the end what
happens the Tyrion ends up leading a
council of elders and they form a
republic in Westeros which you just suck
man no one wants that it's not called
game of Republic's if we wanted to watch
that then we'd watch house of cards and
we'd watch American politics like as it
is now which is more dramatic and far
funnier and crazier
and Game of Thrones if it's a game of
Thrones the honestly all the best
candidates have been killed them the
best person all the smart people died
you know this is one of my pet peeves
about Game of Thrones it really annoys
me every person with a brain has been
killed in Westeros every single one and
we keep hearing about how Tyrion he's he
knows things and he drinks ha ha ha ha
he has not made one good decision the
entire series and somehow he's the
wisest guy there he has somehow failed
as an adviser to Daenerys as an adviser
to Cersei as an adviser to who else he
tried to save Sansa that was a giant
fail everything Tyrion has done his
failed he's a garbage adviser he's tried
to advise Jon Snow giant giant failed
there - he has failed like everywhere
he's a giant fail of a human Tyrion and
he killed the only person in Westeros
who actually knew how things run Tywin
right Tywin was the best character on
the show he was the only person who
thought about things between him and
Olenna Tyrell if they had married each
other and they had ruled Westeros
everything is cool sure it would have
been a dictatorship but at least things
were at least the trains would have run
on time but I mean my goodness it's it
is amazing like Cersei is an idiot I
love that her her grand plan was I'm
gonna blow bleep up my grand plan is I'm
gonna gather all my enemies in this one
place and then blow it up in fully
anti-climactic fashion by the way one of
the most disappointing moments of the
series I mean this full of spoilers but
too late you're here
her blowing up the Sept after they build
up Natalie Dormer who is one of the
better characters on the show and they
just kill her off honestly the last
season had a lot of flaws and and I'm
hoping they can save things I'm hoping
they can save things but they've killed
off the vast majority of interesting
characters so I just gave you my rundown
on what I think happens to everybody I
think Sansa ends up on the council with
Tyrion I think that Jon recedes into the
West maybe he goes back and and ends up
leading the military or something or he
just goes and lives in peace as a farmer
I think that I think Arya ends up
regaining her innocence at some point
they're not gonna kill her off she's -
she's too young but she's they're not
they're not gonna allow her to retain
her cool assassin ways so I'm preparing
for disappointment
just like you should in life because
that's that's just the way life works
and Game of Thrones alrighty
time for a thing I like another thing I
hate
know what we're gonna skip the thing I
like today because Game of Thrones was
the thing I like let's do a thing I hate
instead the thing I hate instead
everybody is ripping on John Wayne no
one cares about an interview John Wayne
did in 1971 you know why John Wayne is
an American icon he's an American icon
because of the movies that he made
that's why he's an American icon do you
know anything about Cary Grant's
political views do you know anything
about Clark Gable's political views do
you know anything about Vivien Leigh's
political views do you know anything
about any of the great movie starts
political views really unless they were
members of the of the of the Soviet bloc
and were prosecuted in Hollywood then we
make a bunch of movies glamorizing them
John Wayne is an American icon because
he's the most famous actor in Hollywood
history and because he made a lot of
fantastic movies and because the image
that Hollywood created of the American
cowboy is one of the enduring images of
the West that is why now there are
people calling for his name to be taken
off the John Wayne Airport in Orange
County because of a 1971 Playboy
interview that he did which showed that
he was really out of touch come on come
on I mean this is of the same ilk as
let's take George Washington's name off
of universities and off of States and
let's get rid of Thomas Jefferson again
the accomplishments of Thomas Jefferson
and George Washington slightly more
important than the accomplishments of
John Wayne but I'm really tired of this
notion that by valorising certain
aspects of people's personal personas
and personalities that we are therefore
green-lighting every aspect of them it's
one of my great pet peeves people do
this with washing oh well if you have a
statue of Washington you're saying it
was okay to own slaves really am i or am
i saying it's a good thing that he
helped establish the United States and
oversaw the Constitutional Convention
and was a great president when there's a
statue of Jefferson am I really saying I
think it was good that he stripped Sally
Hemings and kept her in a form of sex
slavery for years no I'm not saying any
of those things it turns out human
beings are complex they have good things
they have bad things but the part that
we build statues to typically is the
part of them that is good now the reason
statutes should come down is if there is
no good right so Sodom Hussein there's a
statue of Saddam Hussein I challenge you
what is the good thing Saddam Hussein
deserves a statue for if I ask you what
is the good thing Thomas Jefferson
deserves a statue for or John Wayne or
George Washington or any of these folks
I think that the answer is pretty
obvious this is why I think that the the
argument over Confederate statues is
more of an interesting one than the one
over John Wayne you can make the case
the Confederate statues should not exist
by dint of the fact that there is
nothing good that these folks stood for
they were standing for slavery they were
literally fighting for slavery I think
they should be left up as a monument to
America's past I think that not not to
honor them but to remind us that people
can do evil things and justify it to
themselves for decades at a time so I'm
not even a fan of tearing down like
Lenin statues or Saddam Hussein statues
I think that stuff should be left up as
a monument to human evil but with that
said the John Wayne Airport is not a
monument to human evil it's a monument
to a guy who was in some of the best
movies in American history it's
monuments of the guy from True Grit
and she wore a yellow rose and just get
over yourselves honest-to-god people if
these are your big problems John Wayne
can't be we found an interview from a
dead guy fifty years ago and we're so
mad find some new problems find some new
problems already
we'll be back a little bit later today
with two additional hours of the Ben
Shapiro show that's why you should
subscribe otherwise we will see you here
on Monday I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19